okay who is exactly behind promoting
these accusations and protests against
judge Cavanaugh we have an Ingram angle
investigation for you tonight the
women's March has been at the forefront
of the anti-trump movement as we all
know they after the inauguration at the
big protest and are taking the lead now
stating just at a quote we are
organizing and impactful non arrests
direct action to make sure that the
Senate knows that we believe Christine
and demand that they hashtag canceled
Cavanaugh and vote no on his
confirmation the women's March group
counts Planned Parenthood and Natural
Resources Defense Council as their
premier partners both groups have
actively opposed Kavanagh since he was
announced now those groups take on
significance because of their
association with George Soros according
to an extensive study by the media
Research Center 100 of the 544 women's
March partners have received a total of
246 my reading that's right million six
hundred and thirty seven thousand 217
dollars from Soros at last count that's
chump change here to react Rihanna
Arnold James is an empty cabin a
protester from Georgia who learned of
the DC protests from a woman's March
email along with contributing editor of
the American Spectator Jeffrey Lord and
Dave bossy Trump former Trump campaign
co-chair and president of Citizens
United great to have you all on tonight
this is a big week for Washington and
the court in triana I'm so glad you came
on tonight so walk us through how you
found out about what was happening here
well I've always been an advocate and so
through advocating and volunteering with
the women's March and other
organizations not just the women's March
you know you get the emails you get the
updates you find out what's going on and
so when I found out that they were gonna
be here in Washington DC I came from
Georgia so you just came on your own
dime and you're your own you're standing
up and you're your own Freight here yes
I'm not a paid protester
okay
and and when you come here do you get
doing it like instructions like where to
go because I know a lot of people are at
Saint Stephen's Church not too far from
here but their meetup places how does
that work yes
there's meetings and trainings to let
you know you know what to do what not to
do
and things like that and so it's very
organized and it's it's very good to be
with be with everyone what do you do for
a living when you're not doing this I'm
retired I'm a veteran fantastic
and and what about Cavanaugh do not like
what do you know about him what do you
know well I don't have anything
personally against him I just think that
this is a bad look for America I think
that he has not been forthcoming and I
don't believe that we need another
Clarence Thomas situation on the highest
I clerked for Clarence Thomas he's a if
you maybe say if you knew him he was
he's a great guy I'm sure he's a great
guy I'm gonna convince Triana by the
time the end of this segment I'm
convinced I'm convincing you because
Trina is too cool she has 12 kids she's
raised with her husband okay eight boys
eight okay hey boys what could happen in
boys $50,000,000 they should take care
of her a little help for the hotel room
David George Soros is not surprising
that Jeb Soros is behind us and George
Soros paid for the fake dossier paid
Glenn Simpson in fusion at GPS so he's
connected throughout all of the
left-wing activities in this country and
around the world it doesn't surprise me
what I would like to see maybe some a
little consistency from these protesters
maybe they can go out and talk about
cory booker as a groper or maybe they
could talk about keith ellison you know
a battering his girlfriend or maybe you
know senator carper from delaware who
beat his wife maybe we could have a
conversation that's a lot bigger than
just some unfounded quite honestly with
no evidence to back it up no
corroboration no witnesses against Port
Brett Kavanaugh he's these same
Democratic senators are saying they
is guilty until proven innocent that is
not how we're supposed to know and I've
got to say that some of the criminal
justice stuff that's being done actually
President Trump is actually moving on
this issue yes I think they're actually
making interesting coalition's with with
minority groups and others who Norton
normally don't look at the Republican
Party in a very charitable way but part
of what's bringing them together is this
idea that prosecutors are overzealous
and are convicting people who really
don't have a shot at either defending
themselves or convicting them before
they've really had an opportunity to put
on the kind of evidence they need to so
it's interesting that these groups are
kind of turning on there's a backlash
fairness hold on one second Jeffery Lord
you've done and actually you have
experience in this because of your work
and another judicial confirmation that
involved a similar type of swarm tell us
about it yes yes my best friend from
college was his judged D Brooke Smith
who is now the Third Circuit chief judge
Third Circuit Court of Appeals
he was the Reagan chief judge of the
Western District in 2001 when President
Bush 43 picked him to go to the Third
Circuit and they did exactly what they
did to Robert Bork and what they're
doing here and the thing you've got a
you always have to gauge as the groups
behind the scenes for example one
senator had 21 of his 28 questions
submitted to judge Smith that I tracked
down were word for word in some cases
from an internal memo that we got a hold
up from one of these interest groups
they are very very powerful and they
there were 27 of them who ranged who
orchestrated against judge Smith and
they give stories to the press with the
Washington Post have published they did
all they do all of these kind of things
and it's a real serious problem and what
we're seeing here our Democratic senator
is basically what you can't see are the
groups behind these Democratic senators
that are pulling the strings which they
are doing and George Soros as a matter
of fact paid for one of those groups in
2002 well open society foundation has an
enormous amount
of money a huge amount of money like I
spent in any way they want those are the
laws I mean they want to give money to
Planned Parenthood I want to give money
to national resource Defense Council
want to give money of the women's March
he can do it sure I mean what are the
Republicans I mean the Republicans have
to have their own groups like yes we are
we are outgunned I mean they have a very
dedicated Tom Steyer George Soros and
their left they want a Ron you know they
want to rock this vote in the midterm
they do and that's what elections do
have consequences and we need to make
sure that our people turnout in November
trying to do one thing fires yeah I
think it might be signs a dirty black
backfiring China what do you hope to
accomplish with your time here well I
hope to accomplish that that he receives
a no vote and I understand you say poor
Brett but what about dr. Ford what about
all miss Ramirez gonna get her
opportunity right and so that's all
we're asking for that an accurate FBI
investigation be conducted mr. Kavanagh
has not been forthcoming for example he
has not been forthcoming with everything
about his past and what his past he's
been in public service for almost three
decades he's been he's been that's the
problem see that's the problem that's
that's a great sensor you're a judge
you're a judge wouldn't you want to see
the evidence when you want to hear all
sides you know what your 36 years ago do
you know what you're doing I don't know
what the heck do I actually do know what
I was doing 36 years ago I was a child
model for a company and what if somebody
but someone comes along says you did
this you a child model you did this you
do that and you're like no I didn't
there's no one's corroborating the
person accusing you where do you go to
get your good name back but I'll go
anywhere because there's no so why is it
that why can't he ask for FBI
investigation in order to
and that's not the FBI's job and we
learned that from Clarence Thomas and I
don't know him so that's right thank you
connection to you but I just think that
we need to take a polygraph do FB
holographs aren't admissible in court
for a reason guys we're out of time